I already have a tester. So I'll just start filling in the implementation. I
want to go through the longPost, each letter of it. And copy the consonants
into another shorter post. So I'll start out with a string shortPost. And I'll
go one letter at a time. I can't use the increment to skip the vowels. Because
I don't know which ones are vowels until I check. Inside the loop, I'll need to
check if the ith letter is a vowel or not, and if it's not, I'll add it to
shortPost. We've written conditions to look for things that are not vowels
before. This is a different way of doing it. Instead of using if it's a or e or
i, I made a string that contains all vowels, and then I asked that string If it
contains the letter I'm looking at. If this string contains the letter I'm
looking at, the letter's a vowel. So, if it does not contain the letter I'm
looking for, then it's a consonant. In which case, I'll add it to short post.
There's one more important thing that I need to do. I need to actually return
the string. Let's see if it works. Here's our actual, and it's exactly like the
expected.